Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill burn his time for the Thursday afternoon?
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Yeah.
Okay.
How's it going?
Oh,
that's wonderful.
Did you or did that happen this week?
Good for you.
You know what good for you.
Um,
you know,
I,
I'm,
I'm going to be,
oh,
I'm going back down the rabbit hole.
This,
this Thursday.
I know it's supposed to be about you on Thursdays.
Mondays it's about me,
but on Thursdays it's supposed to be about you.
You know what I mean?
You sitting there,
you sit near with that Styrofoam Cup dragging up Cuppa Joe America don't work
without,
you know,
we sing singing those condescending socks to the working man.
Gai puts his fucking pants on one leg in a tab.
Joe Six pack.
Yeah.
Goes to the track every once in a while has an occasional,
so again,
you know,
laughs it a racist joke every 7.2 days,
never questioned it.
Um,
yeah,
I'm going down the rabbit hole this week cause I,
you know,
I,
I would like a little bit credit after the Superbowl for being a fucking
gentleman as a Patriot fan.
Okay.
And you Bronco fans better know what I'm talking about.
I was a gentleman.
You know what's so funny?
A lot of you orange cones get your fucking heads so far up your fucking Bronco
assets that you don't even know what I'm talking about.
You think I'm talking about because you guys kicked my team's Ash,
right?
Not really kicked our ass.
Fucking one in the last second took the whole fucking game to win.
Right.
You think that I'm fucking saying that I was nice that actually rooted for
Peyton manning and the Broncos.
No,
that's not what I'm talking about.
You know what I'm talking about?
You have to,
Tom Brady went through that fucking to deflate gate thing.
Went to the entire baseball season.
Air Pressure.
Okay.
You know,
you would think if that's what happens with air pressure.
What if a certain,
someone had a certain something shipped to his certain house to a certain wife.
Okay.
And that certain someone is in the fucking Superbowl,
Jesus Christ,
if they can make a fucking air pressure and eight month fucking Goddamn story on
Espn,
how long is this thing going to last answer.
Zero seconds wasn't able to fucking story.
Okay.
And you know what?
And I loved it.
It happened.
I loved that they did make a big fucking deal out of it.
You know,
cause I don't think they should.
I think we're all going to be on roids in the future.
In the future,
we're all going to be jacked.
Right?
In the future,
they're going to have like a fucking 80 enrolled or like heavyweight division.
Sorry,
I'm eating a Hershey's kiss.
I just had something salty.
I apologize.
Very rude.
You know,
I'm just saying
what I loved about how that happened is I'm never going to lose another fucking
argument that there is a fucking witch hunt or that was a fucking witch hunts.
Okay.
If you're going to fucking,
you know,
go fucking ballistic about that Horse Shit,
then all somebody has to come out and serves your skus.
Doing I own.
Jude just makes me,
Shit.
I'm good.
How are you?
Where'd you come from?
And then that's it.
It's over.
Done.
I don't know about you guys,
but I don't really have any more questions.
Take it off the board.
Now the case solved.
Um,
fucking unbelief.
I was a gentleman.
Oh,
it was generally me.
Not,
not even naming names.
You know what I'm talking about?
Everybody knows who the fuck I'm talking about.
I'm just being a fucking gentleman.
I'm just a gentleman right now sitting in here and some fucking basketball
shorts.
Eaton Hershey kisses.
Just talking.
Just talking to myself.
Oh,
I'm having another one.
Who's a fucking annoying content.
Makes Hershey's kisses.
I don't fucking get it.
No,
thank God.
We have to make sure that these kisses also doesn't make popcorn.
Or you have to fucking unwrap each goddamn colonel popped.
Right?
Am I doing 80 standup right now?
Why
Urgent?
Urgent.
So small?
You know,
I bet they make bigger ones now for fat fucks.
I gotta look that up.
What should I Google here?
The Hershey kiss for a fat fuck.
I gotta do it now just to see if something comes up.
Do.
My dog looks so fucking cute right now.
She's completely just like,
she has her bed and um,
nobody fucking lies down on a bed like a dog.
Just cause they're pack animals and they don't need their space.
They,
they,
they liked being in each other's spaces,
laying down on top of each other.
She fucking,
she's laying there right now.
She looks like a fucking lion just laying in a cage.
Except she's got a bed.
There was no cage.
Surely doesn't look like a lion.
She was like a dog.
She's chilling.
That's what I'm trying to say.
All right.
How when I say Hershey kiss her,
she is the one chapter,
they have a Hershey kiss
for fat.
Fuck.
You know there's going to be a hit here.
Hershey kisses.
This annoys me.
Irish people taste test her.
She kisses.
Oh,
let me guess.
Sick gonna shit on America's chocolate.
When the fuck go Europe.
Is it just enough already?
You know what I mean?
Isn't it enough that we accepted the fact that you stole Blues Music after we
stole it and then brought it back to us?
We were nice about it.
Didn't we?
Um,
all right.
Albert Albert's supersized supersize Hershey's kits.
And then there's no way they're going to say for fat.
Fuck,
come on bill.
Let's,
let's,
let's be intelligence about this.
All right.
Hershey kiss for supersize,
but then they're not going to be able to say that cause Mcdonald's uses that,
right?
Supersize which all just means for fat fucks,
Kisses giants,
milk chocolate,
seven ounce package images for her.
She kits the Suez.
Supersized.
There they are.
Oh yeah.
You know somebody fucking complaint.
You know some fucking,
you know as people that breathe like biggie smalls,
that kind of out of shape,
they have sleep apnea.
Even when they're awake.
You know,
they called up the Hershey
kisses department,
please.
Oh,
you can work so much.
Okay,
I'm going to burn so many calories.
You know,
it's just so fucking gross to them.
Like it was just gross to you that they just said,
fine,
we'll make a bigger,
you know,
just imagine how much more aluminum foil that was
some poor kid fucking thrown out his back picking up those giant chocolate
fucking kisses.
They're really not that much bigger.
Oh Fuck,
you may have those peanut butter ones.
What am I talking about?
He achieves his Christ.
Let's,
let's continue on here.
So anyways,
um,
I am going to have a good time with that when I go to,
I'm actually going to Cheyenne,
Wyoming in Denver,
Colorado,
and uh,
all the fun I'm going to have in Denver wishing them a happy celebration for the
Super Bowl win and uh,
you know,
and I have a couple of the,
choice words to say
and you know,
the best part is as much as if I don't think I'm going to do it,
but if I do it as much as they boo and as loud as they boo in the back of their
heads,
they know I'm fucking right.
I challenge anyone of you guys,
send me your fucking email right now and you tell me that there isn't some
unbalanced fucking going after the Patriots thing after that fucking horse shit.
If the flight date is an eight month story and that fucking thing is eight
seconds.
Oh,
what a gentleman.
I didn't say shit too.
I alluded to it,
but I,
you know,
still not naming names,
we had protection issues.
Um,
it's not a story
anyway,
so I'm going to Wyoming and a,
I drove through it a long time ago and saw these things that look like deer,
but I knew they weren't,
you know,
so I was just like,
wow,
where the fuck am I?
Even though I knew I was in Wyoming,
right.
It's,
podcasts is all over the place.
Um,
let me,
uh,
so I looked up Wyoming on Wikipedia.
Who's getting here?
I went to Wikipedia.
I didn't even go to Wikipedia.
I just wrote Wyoming.
And Wikipedia always,
always comes up,
right?
It's just a great website.
You know,
you just read a bunch of things about the thing that you looked up and
afterwards you feel like you studied something
and then you throw it out at a party and he'd go,
yeah,
it does.
And then eventually you run into somebody that's an expert on it and then you
realize halfway through it and then he like,
you know,
I had fuck Yale,
walk away doing the,
uh,
the Wikipedia shuffle as you walk away.
So many ways I found out that Wyoming
is,
um,
I bet somebody there named their kid ohmic you know their first name?
Oming
so they can be like Wyoming.
How are you doing?
Sorry.
Jesus.
Brutal podcast.
All right.
This article includes a sort of a listing of the United States,
50,
50 United States by population density cause I immediately found out that
Wyoming,
Wyoming is the
second least densely populated state.
All right,
so here we go.
Let me get to the list here.
Density,
state ranks.
Here we go.
All right,
the top one.
What do you think it is now?
This is density.
This is not population.
This is like elbow room.
Okay.
Density.
Uh,
the most densely populated state is you'd never guess this and this shoot New
Jersey,
I never would have guessed that most densely populated was New Jersey.
That's because of all the costs that can't afford to live in Manhattan right
along the coast,
I think.
Um,
then there's Rhode Island.
It's the number two.
Massachusetts is number three.
It's all the small ones on the east coast with a white man first.
Landed right first started banging away,
first said to the native Americans,
what do you call that stuff back?
And you teach us how to grow it right before they took it from him.
Um,
Connecticut,
Maryland,
Delaware,
New York,
Florida.
Right.
Wherever you loser with a dream from the east coast.
Fucking vacations do with going can you afford my is my cousins has a boat.
Uh,
Pennsylvania in Ohio,
that's the top 10 most densely populated.
I was surprised when he was 11 was not in the top 10.
Granted,
I live in Los Angeles.
All right.
Least populated state.
What do you guess,
what do you got?
What do you got?
Alaska.
All right,
here we go is the top least populated from a number 10 all the way down to
number one,
number one being the least densely populated.
All right.
Kansas and Nevada and Nebraska,
Idaho,
New Mexico,
South Dakota,
North Dakota,
Montana,
Wyoming in Alaska.
So there you go.
And generally speaking,
I guess we are a very densely populated country and uh,
you know,
yeah.
You'd think I would notice that the amount of traveling I've done,
the only time I really noticed it was when I went to Asia and I was like,
Jesus Christ is a lot of fucking people over
here.
You know?
That's all you do when you go to Asia.
You Go,
holy fucking shit.
Look all these stuff.
They'd fucking stuck all these apartment buildings.
Look at them all.
They're all filled.
There's laundry hanging out every window.
Um,
isn't it amazing that there's a billion people in China and they all have shirts
to give a fucking thought about?
Stuff like that.
Like who the fuck made all those shirts?
Yeah,
you'd take with all those fucking pee,
all those shirts that needed to be made.
What do you think that you would know?
Somebody that makes shirts.
I don't know anybody in the clothing industry yet.
Everybody.
Everybody in the fucking,
that's unbelievable.
As much as many rollerblades as they sold,
right?
Everybody didn't have them,
but everybody's got a shirt,
right?
Everybody's got to cover up the junk.
Even the strippers.
Even strippers have to walk out with some clothes right before they take it off.
All right.
This article is about the u s state,
Wyoming Wyoming's estate and our mountain region of West.
We know all this shit.
The United States [inaudible] popular.
It's a,
why the fuck is it?
Come on.
The Western two thirds of the state is covered mostly with the mountain ranges
and the range lands in the foothills of the eastern rocky mountains.
Is this God's country here?
While the eastern third of the state is high,
high elevation prairie known as the high plains.
Cheyenne is the capital and the most populous city in Wyoming with the
population estimate of this is the most populated city in Wyoming.
A population of 62,448 people as of 2013
62,448 people.
Do you realize what a that that that is?
That's a dream.
It's a dream.
You know what the sad thing is?
Most people like myself,
I would go there and I would go crazy because there was nothing to do.
Look at these fucking pictures.
It's almost like a Clint Eastwood movie.
You don't know.
Oh my God,
look at this sunset.
Yeah,
I'd go out of my mind here.
Jesus Christ.
It's fucking unreal.
I mean,
have you,
have you run into a native American that it doesn't even know that they lost?
Right?
Like back in the day when those Japanese soldiers stayed on the fucking islands
and kept fighting,
World War Two is old faithful there.
Yellowstone.
Yellowstone is in fucking Wyoming.
I never knew that.
Ah,
man,
I wish they had the time.
I would drive all the way up there on the John d Rockefeller Jr memorial
parkway.
I would go all the way up there.
Why I'm asking can be a fucking amazing state.
This is all like fucking like,
like the people that live there.
You've got the regular people that are from their generations,
generations of people that you know,
first went across the country and had the balls to pull up stakes from east
coast and go west and uh,
didn't have the balls to continue.
Like all those real men that settled in San Francisco and Los Angeles,
particularly Hollywood,
they stayed there.
Right.
And then what you have now is you have rich Fox and a rich Fox,
meaning just like business people.
And then,
uh,
celebrities.
Celebrities are big on going out there and buying someplace where they can just
get away and clear their head,
you know,
become a singer songwriter or wherever the fuck it is they want to do.
I'd like to do that Shit,
man.
I'd like to fucking run a log cabin out there.
But like one of those,
it looks like a log cabin from the outside,
but on the inside it looks like a house.
Right.
I get updated one,
not a real one with a dirt floor.
And you know,
when some grizzly bear sticking his face through the fucking kitchen window,
like there is a kitchen that's just a fireplace,
right.
Fuck all that.
You know what I mean?
I,
you know,
something,
this is what I always enjoyed most about fucking skiing cause this time of year,
I'm sure there's great skiing.
Uh,
even with global warming,
right?
Which we're not causing.
Evidently from the documentaries that I watched,
I didn't watch him.
I just saw the links and I was just like,
you know,
I'm too fucking busy.
I'm too busy.
I'm staying with the law,
I'm staying with my life,
you know.
Um,
but the thing that I liked most about skiing is after skiing and going down to
the lodge and sitting by the fire and getting shit faced,
you know,
the whole skiing itself and worrying that I'm going to blow out my knee.
I fucking hate skiing,
man.
I respect the hell out of it.
I think it's an amazing workout.
But like a,
I should take a lesson.
I never took a lesson.
I was like,
I could skate right.
And I just started going down the blue square ones,
right.
Then of course you know your ego,
then it's black diamond,
double black diamond.
I don't wear a helmet.
It's really fucking dumb and I don't know how to fall.
And whenever I do,
one knee goes one way,
one goes the other way,
and it's just like,
you know what I should just do.
I should just buy all the ski ship Shit minus the fucking poles in the skis and
then just go do cardio like a fucking maniac for two hours.
Okay.
Then I put all the ski shit on our roll around in the snow,
and then I come walking into the large and just say,
I went down some quadruple black diamond.
I would like an IPA,
right?
And then I sit there,
a couple of snow bunnies come walking up,
right
little have she further and I'm in there.
Um,
but that's not going to happen.
I'm just going to go to Cheyenne and tell some shit jokes.
That's what's going to happen.
You're not sucks is I'm barely into that beautiful state.
Mark my words.
At some point I'm going to a,
I got to do a tour,
uh,
you know,
of all I,
go from fucking Wyoming over to Nebraska,
up through the Dakotas,
through Montana,
down through fucking,
uh,
Idaho,
back over to Yellowstone.
And then I'll fucking hit home.
I had to do one of those fucking runs.
That'd be a fun one.
Cost a fucking fortunate gas.
It'd be fucking city.
There's like nine,
eight hours,
nine hours drives between each of them.
I run into some comics that have done those runs out there and do that is not
for the fucking faith of heart,
get tell you that right now.
But,
um,
I'm definitely gonna do that.
You know,
I'm psyched because I haven't,
I haven't been in Nebraska in a long fucking time.
I used to all of those things.
I was just watching better call Saul and when they were naming some of the
cities,
you know,
I was going like,
I fucking know those Hayes Grand junction.
I bend to all of those.
That's on route 80.
Route 80 goes through Nebraska.
I'm sorry,
what the fuck am I talking about?
Let's,
let's back up here for a second.
Oh,
freckles flew yesterday and the helicopter,
I flew with my instructor by,
and we flew all the way up to Santa Barbara and came back and
was fucking incredible.
And I went along the coastline the whole way.
I was trying to get a,
uh,
a three point,
um,
I need the 3.4 on the Hobbs to have 100 hours.
Right.
And,
uh,
ended up getting a 2.9 because we had a tail wind and I also took the coast back
rather than going along the one on one and down the four oh five who just was
too beautiful to not do it.
And on the way back,
um,
you go over this,
uh,
navy airstrip,
which is restricted area,
but if,
you know,
if they don't have any planes come in and they let you fly over it.
So we were flying along the coast of it and they let us go in and they said,
you know,
and then they came back on the radio and they said they had a couple of planes
coming in to basically keep your eye out for it.
And of course my instructor finds him first and I look,
I go,
dude,
I only see one.
Where's the other one?
I'm like,
freaking out.
He goes,
no,
they're like fucking those FAA teens,
they fly like really close together.
And sure enough,
when they turned the corner,
there was like two of them and they do this fucking sick ass approach that they
do is they come in right turn base and turn final.
And as they come in,
right,
one of them peels away.
Neither one of them lands on the first pass.
They fly right over the warm way.
One of them does a tight circle and the other does a bigger circle and then they
just fucking one lands in the other one comes in right in after him.
It's was fucking insane.
It was funny was the tower was going,
uh,
when Sierra hotel that keep uh,
traffic in sight and I'm like,
yeah,
keeping Traficant site wasn't Sierra hotel.
Then I'm like going like,
like I could do anything if that fucking thing was coming at me.
Like this thing was like in like a,
like
not even like a Lamborghini.
He's like in a Ferrari,
not a four.
I mean up to fucking Batmobile,
right.
Whatever.
It's more like one of those land speed fucking things they have out there in
the,
uh,
the Salt Lake,
whatever the fuck the salt flats,
the fucking salty dirt out there in Utah.
And I'm in this fucking,
I was basically in a Chevy Chevette.
Like if it came at me like what was I going to do other than be like,
and then that would've been
what a way to go.
Um,
but when we were coming back down,
um,
we got to a point on the,
a lot of geography in this one.
We got along this point on the California coast,
which is called a,
I think,
I think dunes point.
I had never flown up there before.
And um,
there's a sick ass fucking house there,
right as you go up there.
It's got like a fucking,
a pool that's shaped like a fucking cutlass was like a sword.
And we will looking at that.
And is it,
as we came down a little bit further,
um,
we saw something splashing in the water and we looked down and it was a whale
coming up by breaching,
I believe is what you call it.
And we did a little loop around,
I got some video,
I'll put that up there.
Um,
it was fucking amazing.
And then there's just this point,
I think it,
maybe it's maybe that was further up and I think it was further up north.
Why don't we came around dunes point,
like all of a sudden you could start to see lax and then Santa Monica,
Culver City,
and then downtown La was one of most beautiful flights that I've been on.
But the big thing was,
um,
I flew by lax and I made all the radio calls,
which is,
you know,
Bravo airspace as I've mentioned before.
And that's like the shit where,
um,
you need explicit permission to go into that airspace where they have to read
your whole fucking tail number.
And,
uh,
I dunno.
It's like you feel like you're fucking talking to God when you talk to those
guys.
So I had rehearsed the radio call like fucking 30 times on the drive down.
And uh,
I was able to say it with enough confidence that he didn't sound too much like
an asshole.
And,
um,
and then let's go through and it was kind of anticlimactic.
I had really built it up in my fucking head.
But anyway,
so I went back,
I got a 2.9,
so old freckle says 99.5,
um,
99.5 hours.
So,
uh,
I was supposed to fly today,
but I was tired and I don't fuck around doing that shit.
I'm just like,
yeah,
I'm feeling tired.
I'm not feeling it.
Fuck it.
Um,
so anyways,
another thing that I was looking up his,
uh,
is beautiful as he states are,
you know,
that I've been going to all of these states that people,
consider flyover states and fucking what the fuck who's on there,
you know,
just shitting all over him even though they're absolutely gorgeous and there's
great people out there is um,
you know,
just to the drug use and that type of shit is really fucking bad at the heroin
man.
Everywhere I go is this fucking heroin problem.
And they keep linking it back to these,
uh,
you know,
people having an injury.
I saw this on real sports.
People have an injury and then they get like whatever they get the fucking,
was it percosets Vicodin.
I know what the fuck it is.
Oxy and that shit.
And then when that runs out,
they still want that high and heroin is cheaper.
And it's just like,
you know,
once again,
once again you would think,
you know,
with all this shit of talking about terrorism,
and people do and shit to this country for some reason,
you can fuck with the food supply and you can get your own countrymen addicted
to heroin.
And as long as you got enough fucking money,
nobody gives a shit.
It's completely flooded.
Isn't that like an act of terrorism?
I out of my fucking mind.
How can you do that to fellow Americans?
You'll ruin in people's lives.
It's fucking brutal.
But it's one of the reasons why I stay out of the politics shit.
You know,
every once in a while I look at the stuff and it just,
I dunno,
it's like overwhelmingly depressing,
you know?
Like,
um,
I saw something the other day on a,
for some reason I was looking up Chelsea Clinton cause I saw her on TV with
Hillary and Hillary was giving a speech,
right?
Yeah.
I,
and I was literally going like,
there's no fucking way I can listen to that voice for four fucking years.
I just can't,
I am not against a woman being president whatsoever,
but you cannot sound like somebody's learning how to play a trumpet.
I just,
I don't give us,
you could have all the answers to the fucking universe.
There's no,
he can't hear what she's saying.
Yeah.
You know,
my dog's looking at me right now.
Like,
really?
MMM.
So anyways,
so I looked up and I was just going like,
how old is she now?
And when I started out in comedy,
she was just a kid.
And,
um,
okay.
Yeah,
no,
she was at that awkward age and it was kind of this nice unwritten rule United
and make fun of her wishing to the fucking awkward age.
Right.
I was thinking,
what's she like?
12 or something like that.
And uh,
I went to go look it up.
You know how old she was?
Fine.
She was in her thirties,
which fucking blew my mind,
even though obviously it was 20 years ago.
Right.
But,
um,
but killed me is what I saw was they had a stat on our wedding.
Do you know her parents fucking through or a $3 billion wedding
like these politicians,
it's so fucking dishonest.
They don't even try to hide it.
It's like,
how the fuck could you afford a $3 million wedding?
Okay.
The most money,
either one of you ever made it public service was,
was being president,
which was 400 grand of fucking year.
Dude,
you make four to fucking grand a,
they're going to whack you in half.
Okay.
You going to maybe walk with 200
okay.
Right.
Nowadays,
probably less than that.
Probably one 95 what a fucking,
you getting off playing for a fucking,
okay.
You gotta fucking $3 million wedding.
A House on fucking math.
His vineyard.
Give me a fucking break.
These conch go around,
right?
All right.
Got Not a Hershey's kiss,
my mom.
So you know,
I'm telling the truth.
MMM.
You guys go around.
They'd just give speeches.
Him and his wife,
two 53 and a grant of fucking whack.
Just given speeches.
Can Imagine paid trainer granted,
listen,
Sonny,
for an hour ago,
right,
right.
For a fucking hour now he got sick.
We Clinton
with that awful facelift that he got,
which just made his head look fucking huge,
you know,
and he's lost all that weight and he got it.
You got to chin,
whatever the fuck he did do his chin.
He yanked at fucker back.
He looked like a bobblehead version of himself.
And I'll tell you,
his shit's Yank back.
So tidy.
Can't even clap anymore.
You know what I mean?
Either that or that's his true feelings about his wife.
Right.
Which you can't blame it.
You really can't blame Bill Clinton for going out and taking a cigar and,
and,
and putting it in that woman.
You know what I mean?
If like that's what he's laying next to in bed.
I mean,
I,
you know,
Jesus Christ,
if,
if I was married to Hillary Clinton,
she would have to have,
you know,
those,
those surgical mass,
that Asian people where when they get sick,
cause they don't wanna get anybody else sick cause they're fucking courteous or
because it's like nine zillion people that live next door get turned into an
epidemic.
I don't fucking know why they do it.
Right.
I would make her aware of one of those all the time because maybe then she'd
sounded like a muted trumpet.
Right.
And every once in a while she'd,
she'd hit a couple of notes that remind me of a miles Davis song and then maybe
I could just stop myself from strangling her in the fucking Oval Office.
Yeah.
She reminds me like an animal that like is,
is getting eaten alive.
You know,
you've been here that like,
just like time I saw that fucking monkey eaten that other monkey alive,
just digging meat out of its back.
And these are like,
it's sort of like,
not as sharp and not as quick as that.
MMM hmm.
Anyways.
And they fucking that,
that Bernie Sanders guys with his fucking night Eo.
You look at and you know,
you wonder why Bill Clinton got a fucking face lift and then you,
yeah,
you're fucking,
he got his neck done.
Then you look at Bernie Sanders,
you're like,
oh,
that's why Jesus Christ,
he looks like a fucking,
he looks like a bloodhound eating a fucking Turkey dinner.
Jowls flopping all around February Joe.
Yeah.
All right.
All of these guys,
that Jersey guy looks all fat and then everybody else just looks like an extra
to me.
Granted,
I have not listened to one fucking word.
Any of them have said,
but it's a,
it's going to be interesting.
Oh,
really?
Bill,
you think it's going to be interesting,
a presidential election that might Pique your interest.
You have freckled arrogant country.
Um,
anyways,
so,
so what else?
I'm doing a,
I'm doing a show tonight.
I got some new fucking material.
I'm really excited about it.
And,
uh,
I want to thank everybody who,
bought tickets out in Cheyenne and Denver,
Denver.
I'm,
I'm not going to come there and shit on your fucking team.
I would do that to you.
I'll have fun with it.
And at the end of the day,
no matter how much I fucking allude to the 800 pound roided up elephant in the
fucking room,
matter how much I allude
to,
that you could just sit back and be like,
well,
it gives a fuck.
We won the Superbowl,
right?
Rocky Mountain had Colorado.
All right,
let's read those out.
Let's do some,
let's do some goddamn rates here for this week.
All right.
Okay.
Me undies,
me,
undies,
me undies.
Your wife's taking HGH pollute.
Do dooby undies,
B and e's.
Sorry.
All right.
This year don't be predictable and show up at Valentine's Day dinner with some
last minute box of chocolates or a bouquet of roses that are going to die in a
week.
Anyways,
shot.
Give the gift.
Everyone is talking about.
Nobody is talking about this underwear.
Hey man,
did you hear about me undies?
No.
Do you want to know?
All right.
Dead.
Show your special someone.
Just how much you care,
what the present.
You'll both love a gift that looks great and feels great too.
Sometimes something that says you deserve the best.
Treat yourself and your boo.
Two a matching pair of me undies.
Creamy the world's most comfortable underwear.
Please include the file Modo,
Modo mod out and the,
and this underwear is coming is as comfy as it gets is coming.
Gross me undies are made of micro modal,
modal fabric,
meaning they're twice as soft as cotton.
You know what?
I'm sick of saying that.
I'm going to fucking look that up right now.
Modal versus cotton bump up bump bar,
Dota,
Dota two to do to the bed.
Bed,
bed,
bed.
Clearly a little tonight and Botha.
Alberta is gone.
A men's underwear fabric types.
The ones considered artificial silk.
Oh,
it's artificial silk.
Holy Shit.
Wait a minute.
Once considered an artificial silk silk,
it was once considered,
considered an artificial silk.
Gross.
What the fuck is that?
Jesus Christ.
All of a sudden this ad cave down and it was a shredded dude.
He looked like a diver.
I remember I was shredded.
Greg Louganis was with these little skivvies on and his fucking package,
Jesus Christ.
They should have been a warning,
the package delivering on the way.
All right.
Once considered an artificial silk modal.
Modal is a type of ray on what these to make slacks in the 70s that's softer
than cotton and it's smooth and theft and breathes extremely well.
They you go,
there you go.
No more sweaty balls and extremely luxurious fabric.
My mistake,
excuse me,
it's cool to the touch absorbent grouse and similar in texture to silk or
cotton.
Unlike cotton,
however,
it is resistant to shrinkage and less likely to fade or pill.
Well,
Jesus Christ,
don't I owe everybody had fucking me undies and apology.
I'll never be a cunt again when I read this.
All right,
the twice the softest cotton.
It's an artificial silk.
Okay,
I'll go with that.
Keeps you balls dry.
It's cool to the touch.
Uh,
and they don't just feel great,
feel great,
they look great to me.
Undies comes in,
tons of cool prince and styles and new designs come out every month.
That sounds like a lie.
Anytime they say tons,
give me a number.
Oh,
there's tons of got to right around the corner.
Just give me the money.
Uh,
you won't want to Miss February is limited edition designed from legendary
artists.
Keith haring.
Oh fuck he Harry.
What the fuck is Keith haring?
Hang on a second.
Keith.
The fuck is Keith haring.
He probably opens for Clinton when he fucking give speeches.
Can I have some over them?
Silky underwear for she sucked my dick.
Keith haring wasn't,
it was an American artist.
This guy's fucking dead.
How the hell is he designed and underwear.
Okay.
1958 to 1990
he was 32 Jesus Christ.
He died young.
He was an American artists and social activists or of course he died.
Those are the fucking people that the government puts shit in.
Your coffee.
Who's work responded to the New York City street culture of the eighties concept
of birth decks,
death,
sexuality in war.
Just she going to put this on underwear.
Okay.
Oh yeah,
the stick figures.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
This guy had his own style.
I actually know what this guy's shit is.
I've seen that before.
I don't get it.
I mean it looks like a fucking better version when I drew in kindergarten.
But then again,
a lot of modern art does it built.
Why don't just read the fucking copy.
All right.
It's retro design is inspired by love making it the perfect Valentine's Day
gift.
Grab yourself a pair and celebrate the holiday sporting matching underwear with
your sweetheart groves and me undies has to keep it for free.
Guarantee has a keypad for free guarantee.
If you don't fall in love with your first pair of keep them and you'll get your
money back.
No questions asked.
So what are they going to do?
A return them and then you're going to resell them.
All right.
This year when Valentine's Day,
head to head me undies.com.
What?
This year when valent this year when Valentine's Day,
head to me,
undies.com/burr now to get free shipping and 20% off your first order.
See that?
I just saw when and then head.
So when head to head,
I went to a sports place.
Um,
don't wait till the last minute.
Get a matching pair of this month's limited edition print while you still can
and get 20% off your first order at Mandy's me undies.com/ [inaudible] that's
[inaudible] dot com slash birth for free shipping and 20% off your first order
of the world's most comfortable.
They were all right.
Legal Zoom,
legal zoom before another year passes is take the time to get your life
organized with legal zoom.
Do you have a family?
Do you have any assets?
They own property,
Benny.
Those answers were yes,
you should have an estate plan.
Don't worry if that sounds,
if that sounds complicated,
legal zone can help legal zooms a state plan.
Bundles,
uh,
eliminate the guesswork.
You don't have to figure out on your own.
You don't have to figure out on your own whether I will or living trust works
best for you.
Instead,
you work with an independent attorney available in most states it wouldn't.
And then how you'd do it anyways.
Uh,
they'll walk you through the options and recommend in a state plan that best,
uh,
that offers the best solution to fit your needs.
Since legal zoom is not a law firm,
you can count on efficiency and value.
Yeah,
it's such a weird sentence to me.
Everything is on you.
Yeah,
we're not a lot from a fucking breeze.
Right through this,
everything is on your schedule and your turns.
Plus you'll know what your estate plan bundles costs up front instead of
worrying about our lead rates.
That's how legal zoom has become the leader and helping small business owners
and families with their legal needs.
You get legal help and you'll walk away feeling great.
God Damn,
that was awesome.
Get your life organized with an estate bundle@legalzoom.com today.
Don't forget to enter burpee.
You are in the referral box at checkout.
That's Code burr@legalzoom.com.
All righty.
There we go.
All right,
that's going to be the Thursday afternoon podcast.
Once again,
Andrew Feminists is going to give you some cool music that I know nothing about,
um,
as he does every single week.
Uh,
thank you guys for listening.
I hope you have a wonderful weekend.
You can't send Bronco fans.
I'm just fucking with you.
Okay.
I don't give a shit.
You think I'm not going to be on Roids when I'm,
you know,
I was going to say older.
I'm going to be 48 this year,
so I should probably start taking it,
you know,
start showing up to gigs with no neck.
You know,
seeing if people fucking,
dude,
you know what fucking Peyton Manning's neck and head look like.
Do you remember when Steve Buschemi got stuck in that chipper in Fargo?
Do you remember when his leg was just sticking out with the foot?
That's what Peyton Manning's neck looks like.
You just stick a head stick ahead on it.
Sorry,
I got the hiccups.
All right,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
Enjoy the throwback podcast for the last half an hour in the wonderful music.
I'll talk to you on Monday,
you cunts.
[inaudible]
Valentine's Day advice Billy by deer is billion.
I know this is last minute.
I had a question about Valentine's Day.
I am a single guy in my mid twenties rejoice.
Okay,
dude,
I'm going to tell you right now,
if you're a single guy in your mid twenties and you live in America and you're
living on your own,
please
drop to your knees and thank whatever gods you pray to everyday because you're
never going to be freer in your life.
I know you've probably got student loans and blah,
blah,
the stress and all that bullshit.
Fuck that.
Okay?
Getting never going to be freer in your life.
Go get three years supplies of condoms,
okay,
and bang away my friend.
Maybe you don't need to do it for three years.
Maybe you're one of those guys for only three weeks,
but you need to get it out of your system.
All right?
He says,
I never really had a girlfriend for whatever reason.
Oh Jesus Christ.
All right,
we're going the whole other other way.
Truth be told,
my friends could name numerous reasons why I don't have a girlfriend,
but that's an entirely different issue.
What?
Jesus Christ as a fucking can of worms.
They can.
You don't seem defensive or argumentative.
So I don't know if it's an anger issue that,
look,
I'm so,
I'm so sick of trying to be fucking Hannibal Lecter here.
Trying to guess what your shoes look like with w with the way you write,
you know.
All right.
I'm just gonna read the rest of this shit.
Uh,
as of right now,
I am currently sleeping with three girls off.
Oh,
see you fucking have good knocking it out.
I thought you'd like never had a girlfriend,
like in like never bagged anybody.
All right.
My fault.
Do go fuck yourself.
You're a guy in your mid twenties and you fucking three girls right now and I'm
on this.
You need advice?
I keep doing what you're doing
anyways,
depending on what day of the week it is and how much I've drank.
Okay.
That depends on how many girls he's banging a,
I've never lied to anything,
any of any of them about where our relationship going.
And although they never met each other,
each of them has an idea that I'm seeing other girls.
It's kind of a don't ask,
don't tell policy.
Um,
yeah,
dude and I,
you got to come with that.
You know,
you can open with that.
what are you doing?
I'm dating,
I'm playing the field.
Find people you date right now.
A couple of people kind of see it just having a good time.
Well,
I don't do stuff like that.
Well there's the door sweetheart.
Yeah.
Then they'll respect like that.
The honesty of that.
Some won't.
Some will actually have self esteem and walked out,
but a lot of them know,
hang around.
Eventually they get tired,
they're net gets weak and they'll fall right in your fucking Dick.
Um,
birthdays and Christmas are always a piece of cake because all that requires a
quick text or a phone call or at the very most drinks at the bar.
But Valentine's Day is tricky.
Our dates consist of bar hopping and drunk sex.
So flowers and a nice dinner would completely send the wrong message.
Dude,
you selfish con.
Are you asking me how to keep banging these three chicks while getting through
Valentine's Day?
Why don't you just look at the Valentine's Day like that's your pussy getting
all star break.
Just take three days off the day before the day after and the day of.
Okay.
Just say a,
what are you doing for Valentine's Day?
Um,
uh,
I'm going to be a Jesus.
Where are you going to be?
I don't know.
I don't have a good one for that one.
All right.
You know what?
I just put myself in your shoes and I understand your problem now.
He said,
I got to do a little bit of trouble.
Last year one of the girls texted me and said,
you know every girl likes flowers on Valentine's Day.
Yeah.
He said,
I knew my response couldn't be.
Yeah,
but if I get you flowers then I have to get flowers for all the other girls.
So I just post out and responded.
Yeah.
Well,
oh dude,
you shouldn't respond to responded at all.
Okay.
You know,
every girl likes to get flowers on Valentine's Day.
Isn't that funny?
Okay.
And that has nothing to do with most likely her having any sort of feelings
towards you.
It's just the bitch next to her in the other cubicle probably got some,
you know why the girl on her fucking whatever the fuck you want to call it.
Some guy broke my balls this week is fucking hilarious.
It was trash and we say come off as a pompous ass because I always talk about
anybody who doesn't do comedy works in a cubicle,
you know?
And for some reason he decided to take that seriously and tell me that he
actually works at the UN and travels all around the world.
If that's actually true.
Sarah,
how?
Why don't you just get on with doing that?
You work at the UN and you travel all over the world.
Why would you give a fuck what some absolute jackass is?
Say It on a fucking podcast.
How insecure are you?
Your insecurities?
Probably a great thing because that's probably the thing that drove you to be at
the UN.
What you travel all around the world.
You know sir,
good for you.
That's awesome.
I hope working at the UN and traveling all around the world fills you up some
point where it fills you up high enough.
What?
You don't have to respond to a silly joke on some dumb ass podcast.
Um,
I travel all around the world.
you know what?
That's actually a great fucking job.
Do you feel like you get anything done?
You know,
do you sit there and wearing that headpiece next to that guy who's wearing the
water buffalo hat?
[inaudible] above doing that shit.
And you're sitting there trying to talk to him about how you can sell your rich
crackers to their country.
Is that what you're doing when you're traveling all around the world?
I travel all around the world.
I can just see you on the plane with you fucking dress socks on.
You have a dash cunt.
Oh,
just sitting there.
Or what movies am I going to watch on this flight as I travel all around the
world?
Um,
anyways.
You know something sir,
you had you,
you had the James Bond job and then you fucking,
you played yourself.
I don't know why you did that.
Why would you fucking,
that's like me responding to people on Twitter.
Why would I do it?
I should pretend like I have better things to do.
Um,
anyways,
I want to keep seeing all these girls back to this guy,
but this,
but at the same time,
I don't want any broken hearts on Valentine's Day.
How to do you know what golf?
I did it.
I don't,
I'm just,
what is your problem here?
Okay,
dude.
Yeah,
you like a Gemini.
It's like you're this fucking lady killer.
Then also you kind of like,
you know,
you want to hurt anybody.
Should I get her some jam jams?
I can't even,
I talk to the fucking UN guy.
What the hell was going on here again?
Okay.
Valentine's Day got a little trouble last year.
Well,
listen,
you're anticipating trouble.
Didn't you learn anything from last year?
You know,
every girl likes flowers on Valentine's Day.
Okay.
Um,
what,
what would I write back?
I know what my response would be.
The second I read that if it was just some girl I was banging and then they
wrote that I would get this awful feeling in my stomach
and I would,
I would read it and as I got that awful feeling,
I'd go
and make that noise.
Okay.
You know that thing,
like when you're just banging a girl and then all of a sudden she just fucking
makes that comment.
Okay.
You know,
you think she's on the same page as you when she just makes that comment.
I was thinking about you today and you just feel that feeling in your stomach.
Oh yeah.
Well,
don't
fucking worst.
Uh,
you gotta be one and done,
but one had done is scary.
Okay?
You just gotta be honest.
I don't know if some girls,
what would I say?
You know,
every girl likes flowers on Valentine's Day.
Um,
what would I text back?
Yeah.
You know,
that's what I heard.
You know what I mean?
You know what?
I shouldn't give you shit.
I don't have a good response to that.
Well,
maybe someday you'll meet a guy who wants to give you some,
you want to get drunk and fuck.
Um,
yeah,
I got nothing and you can't ignore it.
You know what I would've done?
I would have ignored the text and I would have called her.
Okay.
But a good three hours later,
three,
four hours,
three hours later,
that's a good one.
You call her,
you ignore that text and they call it,
she goes hell out.
And you're like,
Hey,
what's going on?
What are you doing tonight?
I got no plans Valentine's Day.
What are you doing?
And he just started with that.
And then she,
well,
what do you want to do?
And she'll be seen.
If you're going to take it to some romantic,
you know,
direction you need,
don't you just keep it in the fuck buddy?
Well,
I figure we'd go down to a mean hammers,
whatever the fuck he call,
we'd go down to,
uh,
take it the face.
I have a couple pitchers of beer and see what happens.
Dude.
You know what?
You're,
you're,
it seems to me you're not just fucking these girls.
You're actually having like these many relationships with them.
You know,
the,
the key to have an a fuck buddy is,
is the time between fucking him.
And I don't give a shit how much a woman says that she can handle it.
Most of them can't.
If you fucking come on over there and you,
and it just,
eventually they're going to get feelings.
They're more,
I dunno if they're more mature or if it's a defect.
It's just,
I just respect the fact that that's how they're wired.
So you,
if you have a fuck buddy,
okay,
let's,
let's just do the math.
Okay.
No,
no.
February is a very short month here.
So let's just say right out of the gate.
You fucker on February 2nd
okay.
All right.
You shouldn't come around again till at least the 17th
and progress.
You fuck.
And you leave f and l,
you fuck them and then you leave.
You don't bang her on the second.
You Bang it on the second and then you bang her on the seventh year in a fucking
relationship in their world.
You know,
unless you,
literally this second you have an orgasm as you're coming,
you're scooping up your clothes and you walk out like half naked,
then you just bizarre.
Just another good way to keep them at bay.
And why don't I just read the rest as to see what,
what his question is here.
He says,
I want to keep seeing all these girls,
but at the same time I don't want to break.
I don't want any broken hearts on Valentine's date.
Yeah,
you want to keep fucking all of them?
No.
Do what you have to have.
You have to have a role evolving door.
You have to have a stable of women.
If you're going to live this life or you have to give into fucking rubbing one
out,
all right?
But you can't be a relationship guy with three different women cause you are
going to end up hurting them.
So what you have to constantly be doing,
you gotta be like a college coach,
all right?
Every year you lose some top prospects,
but you're out there recruiting.
Okay.
See you.
So you maintain,
but it's never ending.
It's fucking exhausting.
But if that's the game you want to play,
that's what you have to do.
So that girl who says,
you know,
every girl likes flowers on Valentine's Day right there,
you put on waivers,
okay,
for a fucking piece of ass to be named later you got,
he got to get rid of her.
Okay.
And you got to look,
go back and analyze what the fuck you did wrong that she felt it was okay for
her to text you cause you fucked up.
That right there shows that you fucked up,
that she felt that she could send that to you if you think you're just fucked
buddies.
All right?
So anyways,
he continues.
He says,
I know that like it or not,
this shit is important to women.
If I take one girl out,
I'm playing favorites and setting a bad precedent.
Plus if she does that check in Shit on Facebook,
I'm completely fucked.
Yeah Dude,
you're doing dirt bags.
Shit.
If you're a single guy and something could happen that fucks you on Facebook,
you're leading these girls on anyways.
He says,
if I take none of them out or do nothing,
I have three irritable ladies on my hand.
Dude,
are you going to marry any of them now?
Well then let them go.
Why don't you have the balls to do that?
You know,
when a team halfway through the season,
just realize,
do we ain't winning this shit?
Just pull a fucking Marlin's.
Just get rid of everybody
and then your fan base is your Dick and they're going to,
he's going to be pissed for awhile.
Um,
but then you build it back up again.
Build it back up again.
You know,
I dunno.
Look through it.
If you want to be in a fucking relationship,
you know there's other ways about going about it and doing this,
but you're trying to have your cake and eat it too.
Did you get you,
you got the three women right now,
your bang in three different women.
Where's your confidence?
You know what you're doing.
All right,
dump to keep one at bay and then get two more.
Then dump the other one to get the other one.
Just see if you don't even dump them.
You just phase them out,
phase them out.
But the new recruits that you get in,
you gotta be straight up honest with them,
you know,
unless you actually feel fails,
you feeling no feelings,
you know,
don't keep coming back fucking him unless,
you get that 15 day,
you fuck,
I'm on the second.
You fuck them on the 17th,
then you're into march and then banger on like the 11th.
Okay.
All right.
And even then,
they can't catch feelings doing that.
But before you know it,
you know,
okay,
that's like 14,
15 days out of the year taken up.
Boy,
you,
well you got the bank.
Somebody,
this is such,
this is,
this is really should be eye opening to women that I'm actually saying this is
really a,
this is really awful that I'm speaking this out loud.
Um,
he says,
in a perfect world,
I'll take all of them out at once and have the force and I've been chasing after
my entire life,
but we don't always get what we want.
Any advice from the lovely new would be much appreciated as well.
Love the podcast.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Uh,
yeah,
she probably wouldn't have been his,
uh,
understanding as I was going to give you a lot of shit.
Wow.
I've been asking some to write it.
And uh,
finally
I haven't even read this yet,
but this already seems like gold.
This is,
this is the,
the
and the subject line of this email.
It says,
I think the guy I'm dating is a pussy.
Hello Bill.
I am a 21 year old student.
I began listening to your podcast recently and I heard you complaining about how
women have not written in a while and being a woman myself decided to do so.
It asks you for advice.
Well,
God bless you.
Uh,
I live at home with my mom and go to college.
I recently found a very nice guy.
Uh,
there were college and was really into them,
but then I started suspecting something strange.
I started suspecting that maybe he was a pussy.
At first I thought it was pretty harmless,
but then one night we had a house party and everyone was pretty drunk.
And a friend of mine who I haven't seen in a while was there.
And when everyone was way,
way,
way past drunk.
She tried to get into a fight with me and eventually pushed me down the wall,
then stole my iPhone and he was there and did nothing.
Jesus Christ.
I was so scared that I called my ex to come get me any did.
Wow.
You think you're dating a pussy?
I mean that right there g and he just stood there and let this other guy who
used to hook up with you come in riding in on his white horse.
Anyways,
my ex was more of a man than the guy was dating now,
even though the guy I'm dating was drunk,
I felt like he should have protected me or done something,
anything.
He did nothing and later he even confessed to me that he was scared of my drunk
for friend and even scared of me.
What the fuck?
Right?
Even though he says this will never happen again.
I have enough knowledge to know that people do do not usually change like that.
You know?
That's a really wise that you're really wise for your age of 21.
If you,
if you were already not buying into the,
I'm going to change.
That's a,
you're,
you're wise beyond your years.
You know,
they say that you're basically,
your psychological makeup is done by the time you three.
So if you see some little toddler standing,
there was somebody taking his blocks,
that kid's going to be a pussy
anyway.
So should I be upset or give him another chance?
Is this a deal breaker?
Is there no way to change a guy from a pussy to a real man?
Should I just break things off with him and if so,
should I remain friends with him?
Thanks bill.
And I hope you read this.
Uh,
I love you India.
Oh,
that's nice.
Um,
all right.
This is the deal.
Uh,
you asking a question?
Is there no way to change a guy from a pussy to a real man?
Okay.
No,
I don't think,
I think that that happens.
I think it happens way more in movies where somebody has a life changing moment.
Uh,
and then they just decided I'm not going to take shit anymore.
But even then,
that just begins the journey of not being a pussy.
You don't just say,
I'm not going to be a pussy and then Bam,
you're not a pussy anymore.
You have to,
you got to work your way up.
It's like if you were a hundred pounds overweight and you like this,
I'm done.
I'm not eating fucking ice cream anymore.
The next day you don't have a six pack,
you know,
it takes a fucking year or something.
You really got to turn it around.
So,
um,
I dunno,
what are you looking for in a guy?
I mean,
I think the fact that you're writing me and you're saying,
I think the guy I'm dating as a pussy,
I mean that,
that actually hurts me on some level just because I insert myself into this
story and the person I'm dating would be calling me a pussy or it could it be
the ex,
I guess.
I Dunno.
This isn't about me.
This is about you come up,
you'll stop being selfish.
Alright.
Um,
I think you've totally lost respect for this guy.
And if you don't respect the person you're with,
eventually you're going to blow somebody else.
Okay.
You know,
if you don't break up with this guy,
that's what I'm predicting.
If you don't break up with this guy,
you're just going to cheat on him just to facilitate.
Yeah.
Getting out of the relationship because uh,
okay.
You know,
to get to that ll cool j moment,
we can just be fucking honest.
But I don't think you'll like that.
I when something about you knowing that people don't change at your age and the
fact that you like,
you know,
this guy's a pussy,
he's not sticking up for me.
And the fact that he didn't stick up for you and then you took charge and say,
well I'm going to fucking call somebody who will.
Okay.
I mean technically you should have fucked your ex boyfriend that night and he
and he shouldn't have been mad.
He should have been like any,
probably wouldn't have that cause he's a pussy.
I ain't,
I understand.
I mean,
you know,
when you needed a big swinging Dick,
I mean,
God knows it wasn't me.
So,
uh,
yeah.
Um,
I think if you don't break up with this guy,
you were actually fighting nature.
All right?
And
Yeah,
you guys are wired to,
to,
okay,
I know you guys aren't wired to just have kids with pussies.
You know what I mean?
You want a strong sun,
right?
You don't want like,
you know what that Pussy Dna and your kid,
right?
All that's going to kill you.
Imagine that you have a kid with this guy and you want this kid to be like a,
like your ex boyfriend and it comes down and it's like this fucking little wormy
worm guy.
Ah,
that'd be awful.
Walking down the aisle to marry this guy with dead sheepish and you know,
these deserve you again.
You know what dad,
you want this guy to be the man standing down there and a white Tuxedo like
fucking Roger Moore,
James Bond,
I think.
I think,
uh,
look,
I don't know if this just happened and you're really upset.
So,
uh,
you know,
and like,
and in three days you're not going to care and you get to go back to having a
picnic with this guy because for all I know,
your ex who came coming back,
maybe you broke up with him because he cheated on you.
Maybe he was too much of a guy,
if you know what I mean.
So then you said,
well,
all right,
I'm going to,
maybe I'm this next time I'm dating a nice guy.
He's now you dated a nice guy.
The thing about is sometimes you date a nice guy.
They can be so nice that they're pussies.
Alright,
and look,
I'm not,
I'm not sitting there acting like,
you know,
if I'm out with my girl in some fucking 200 pounds,
300 pounds jacked fucking 25 year old comes up and starts doing shit that I'm
going to start swinging because I'm not,
I'm not,
I'm not getting my fucking head kicked in just for the fuck of it now.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
it's not like just,
okay,
you know,
straight across the board as a guy you have to fucking go and get your Goddamn
head kicked in.
But this was a fucking woman.
This was a lady.
I mean Jesus,
it's the,
it is a weird situation in defense of him were,
yeah,
how do you get the fucking iPhone back?
You start wrestling with her and now you're kind of fucking throwing a girl
around so you're looking at that possible assault charge cause God knows that's
how the world worked.
Works right now.
Your honor.
I was trying to steal a phone and he,
this guy is salted me and you're going to be sitting there going,
she was stealing a phone and then I can be able to get past your,
you're a guy and she's a girl.
But um,
yeah,
he should have just,
he should've just held her by the back of her pants so she couldn't leave and
just stayed out of reach of her swinging.
That's what you do.
If you're in that situation as a guy,
he just reached out,
you grabbed by the back of their pants and you just start running in a circle
until cops get there.
So they can't swing at you.
They're running backwards.
I mean,
I don't know what you,
you gotta you got to fucking do something and he didn't do anything.
That's the big thing that if you told them,
honestly,
if you told me that this was some giant guy who could kick the shit out of him,
uh,
I wouldn't say that the guy's a pussy.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
what is the point of going in and getting a concussion?
Getting your tooth driven up through your fucking nose.
The guy's still going to leave with your phone.
You know,
that's that old,
uh,
Richard Pryor.
Bit Macho,
man.
I'll take that knife and stick it up your ass macho man.
It's like,
no,
you're going to get the shit kicked out of you.
But this was a woman.
All right,
bill,
for fuck sakes.
Quit.
You have God damn rambling.
Wrap it up.
Um,
I think you know what you want to do when you should do it.
you are dating a pussy.
The fact that when he was sober,
he said that he was scared of her and a view.
Uh,
he seems like he's a little for collect and uh,
I just can't imagine where it's going to be a stereotype.
But a guy like that actually putting it on you in the bedroom.
I really don't.
He probably stares at you and the I,
am I hurting you?
Is Everything okay?
God,
you're so beautiful.
I mean,
come on right.
Flip her over and wash your face in the pillows.
I'm always,
she says in ps,
don't worry.
Uh,
that I used to call a friend who pushed me and took my phone is no longer in my
life.
Did you get your phone back?
Well,
what happened with you guys?
Now wait a minute.
What?
Like them?
Can I hear the followup here?
There's so many different ways that this could be gone.
Was that like a girl?
Like when you thought that maybe you were a swing in another way and all of a
sudden you broke up with her and
I get them into the biggest,
dumbest fucking fight last night with my girl,
right?
We had this great day,
everything's going great.
So I stay in,
I take a night off from comedy and I say,
Hey,
why don't we watch,
why don't we watch a movie?
You know what I mean?
Cap Off this wonderful fucking day.
Everything's going great.
What could go wrong?
This is like the beginning of a horror movie where they just show like the
perfect family and everything's great and people are wearing like white linen,
you know?
And then all of a sudden they just start showing the camera and the bushes like
a POV of like Mike Myers.
This is basically what happened.
So 60 minutes comes on,
right?
Who doesn't want to watch that show and pretend they're smart?
You know,
I like it some more Morley safer comes on and you know,
we smells like an old person.
Some old people don't smell like old people,
but he looks like he smells like an old person,
you know,
smells of cigars,
ash trays,
you know,
a couple of wars,
maybe a date rape.
Um,
so he's interviewing Meryl Streep,
all right.
The Great Meryl Streep,
and they're going through all oral,
oral frigging life and all the movies and all the different characters that
she's played.
Oh,
first of all,
they start,
they start the report off with Morley safer just sitting there,
right?
Smelling a fucking Ben Gay and Whiskey,
right.
And uh,
he says,
how,
you know how over in England,
you know,
they,
I dunno,
they make their,
their actors,
they,
they award them by calling them lords and they night them.
But over here in America,
all we do is just give them the shiny statue and it's just like,
starts off right off the bat for some reason,
just shitting on America.
I don't know why.
Like an Oscar is somehow beneath
sir,
uh,
Anthony Michael Hall.
I mean,
or,
or Lord,
what it Lord of what,
what are what lease.
You can fucking hold our statue,
your Lord.
Of what kingdom,
that phony horse shit that you have with Prince Charles and the popper or
whatever the fuck is going on over there,
you know,
look up the Rothschild's night,
you over there,
then that fucking means something.
Then you can come become part of their yacht.
Convoy is they go around the world figuring out how to take over another
currency,
right?
Then you're in with them.
Okay.
But if you're,
if you're fucking,
you know,
Lord of this and your,
your wing man is the Duke of Elton John.
I mean,
that's a whole thing is fucking stupid,
right?
So right off the bat,
it's already bugging me,
but I know near hates when I talk to the TV,
right?
So I,
you know,
I keep my big fucking Yap shut and they started talking about Meryl Streep Up,
up,
up a bog on through the whole thing.
And then I'm the old guy there smelling of a,
you know,
prescription meds goes,
uh,
you know,
whenever they talk about the roles you play,
they always say,
you know,
he played independent minded women,
very strong women.
And Merrill goes,
I know that's,
yeah,
that's what they say.
You know,
when a guy,
they never say to a guy,
oh,
you're playing a strong willed character,
Yadda Yadda,
Yadda.
I let that go.
Whatever,
no biggie.
I'll take that.
It's probably true.
The fuck do I know I'm not a Horman.
Right.
But then they show her after she played Margaret Thatcher,
and she's given a speech to a bunch of women's young girls and she's trying to
inspire them and she,
she takes a quote from Margaret Thatcher who was something along the lines of,
if you want a bunch of people to talk around,
talk standing around talking about doing something,
you know,
something,
I go,
you got to talk to men.
But if you want it to actually get done,
you got to get a woman.
And then all the chicks go,
Woo.
Like flipping out.
Right.
So I laughed and I'm like,
Yay.
Reverse sexism.
Right.
Just seeing,
you know,
my,
my whole fucking theory,
how everybody is just a piece of shit.
You just don't have the power to act out what the fuck you want to do because
that,
that right there,
if you flip that around as a guy,
if you're running for president,
it's fucking over.
He can't be like,
let me tell you.
I'll tell you what,
after I get you jobs and after I fixed this economy,
okay?
And I'm the man to do it because I'll tell you right now,
if you're looking for someone to stand around and talk about doing something,
you get a woman.
You want to get it done.
You got to get a man.
Here are my nuts right here on the podium.
Vote for me.
November 4th go fuck yourself.
Right?
You did that.
Your presidential campaigns over.
She does it.
It's fucking adorable and it's just as fucking ignorant.
You know what I mean?
What a fuck do you get off saying that we stand around and do nothing.
Meryl Streep.
Ah,
or quoting Margaret and youtube.
Margaret Thatcher.
Let me tell you,
you bitches something.
Alright,
we faked a fucking lunar landing.
Okay?
You think that's just talking.
Anybody can land on the fucking moon.
That's easy.
But to pretend you did it all right and get everybody to shut the fuck up about
it.
That,
that,
that right there,
that takes skill.
So whatever.
So I make that little comment and um,
did I just go with that?
That,
that,
that's the only fucking porky pig.
So,
so I make that comment and like,
you know,
I've been with Nia long enough that I can tell by the side of her face when
she's just thinking about like,
what if I grabbed everything I really cared about and walked out of this house
right now?
She got like that fucking mad at me,
you know?
Okay.
And I'm like,
she's just like,
right after the story was obviously just shut the fucking thing off and uh,
I won't happen next sale.
I'm walking to seven 11 and get some ice cream.
I haven't,
I've not even,
what happened was all going great.
You know,
am I be asshole there?
What am I?
Am I supposed to just fucking sit there with my mouth hanging open with drool
coming out when I watch TV?
If somebody says something Douchey,
I'm not supposed to say it.
Yeah,
whatever,
whatever.
So I just finally just said,
you know what?
Fuck this.
I take the dog out.
I go around the block.
What do I do?
I'm calling my guy friends,
right?
They're all backing me up.
I'm not saying who I called.
I don't name names.
All right.
And they're all laughing their ass off and they 100% agree with me,
which is all I'm looking for at this point.
I just want people to say that I'm right.
I don't want to learn anything from this experience.
Just tell me I was right.
So it can be an ignorant ass again.
I don't know.
Why don't you guys weigh in on that?
Am I a Dick for saying that?
Should I just let that one go?
You know?
Uh,
you know what she said?
That fucking drove me up the wall.
She goes,
why are you
okay?
She didn't say intimidated.
Okay.
She's one of those words.
Yeah.
Why are you threatened by what she said?
It's like I'm not threatened.
I,
yeah,
Jesus Christ.
Then I take the bait,
you know,
it just sends me right over there like threatened about what?
Oh my God.
This person that I don't know who has never called me,
nor will ever call me,
who has no effect on my life.
How do you get threatened by that?
I'm just calling it for the bullshit that is,
cause you know what?
This is what fucking drives me nuts.
I can't stand when somebody tells me that they're shit sandwich tastes worse
than my shit sandwich.
Okay,
go fuck yourself.
At what point am I supposed to have empathy as I'm sitting here eating the shit
sandwich and you're telling me how much worse yours,
yours,
this,
you know,
at the end of the fucking day.
You know what I mean?
Sure.
Mine might be on a,
you know,
a better slice of bread,
which I guess would make it taste a little bit better,
but at the end of the fucking day,
right?
The end of the fucking day.
All right,
I'm going to end up in a FEMA camp with you.
Okay.
You think when the next fucking a psycho comes along,
I'm going to make the cut.
What the fuck do I,
what do I bring to the world?
Huh?
Exactly.
I'll be standing right next to you.
So go fuck yourself.
You just fucking woman.
Every time she sneezes,
they give her another God damn award.
She's still pitching.
Still fucking bitching.
You know it's rich.
I remember when I did this Oscar nominated part.
Oh go fuck yourself with your wigs.
The thing just,
you know,
that's what fucking pisses me off when I watched this shit.
If you want to know my perspective is from where I come from,
I can't bitch about shit cause everybody's like,
oh go fuck yourself.
You hit the lottery.
Right?
But I got to sit here and listen to you bitch.
Even if you fucking killing it,
even if you killing it,
you know Yale School of drama and he's still up on the bull.
Go Fuck yourself with your God damn yachts.
Alright,
there you go.
That felt good.
It's probably ignoring or whatever.
Y'All know.